Thank You creatures little sucker right
here just rearranges molecules to create
anything you want in the universe okay
let me get this traitor right now I'm
just you know so I understand things
here all right you mean to tell me this
thing can make anything like I don't
know let's say I want it up brand new
Porsche oh this is awesome
you guys should give this thing a better
name an energy trader you should call
the magical super wonder dream machine
Oh energy traders a little more accurate
because that's what you just did huh you
just traded five years of your life for
this bad boy what I'm not even into cars
well I think you'll like this one
I got you the Sport Package five years
okay Wow well that's a great detail to
know okay this is still amazing I just I
got to be careful and stick to the
essentials yeah
yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
hi guys wish me luck tonight Oh get this
dead